[Music]
[Applause]
hey what is up guys how are we doing and
welcome back to another video now today
we're looking at the RX 570 a graphics
card that's pretty much all about priced
performance and this one that I've got
here is from Sapphire it is the Nitro
plus and it's a little bit more
expensive than some of its rivals
including its own pulse uh around about
£1 more at the time of filming but it
pretty much has all the features you
would want from a graphics card and it
isn't overly expensive either so is this
something you should be buying or is
this something maybe you should be
avoiding well to answer that question as
always we start by taking a look at the
design of the card which I have to say
looks very impressive I don't think it's
overly difficult to make a two-tone
neutral design card look good but sappi
have excelled here and it's something
that I'd be very proud to have in my own
system the front of the card features
two fans as a part of a two fan two slot
design thermals are very good I mean
this thing remains pretty quiet even
Under full load and if you aren't gaming
then the fans won't be spinning at all
unless you're doing something
particularly intensive at the top of the
card we've got the sapphire logo and
this is illuminated with RGB which is
one of the main features of going for a
slightly more expensive card like this
we have two power connections we've got
an eight pin and a six pin although I
think you only need to use the eight pin
the six pin is if you want to overclock
this card at least that's what it says
on the box and then around the back of
the card we've got a back plate which
again looks very nice I like the design
here there isn't any RGB but on a budget
friendly card not really something I
think most people will miss and the back
plate of course should stop the card
from sagging a little bit and some
people will say it will help with
thermals but realistically I don't think
it's going to make too much difference
then moving around to the left hand side
of the card where we've got the io we've
got two HDMI sockets and these are HDMI
2.0 we've got two display port 1.4s and
then one DVI port as well so you pretty
much got everything covered if you want
to use freesync then it's going to be
the display port or the HDMI sockets
depending on the Mona set you have
currently got so that's pretty much
everything really you need to know about
this graphics card from a design point
of view what's this thing's performance
like and is it worth buying well I've
already mentioned that this card runs
pretty quietly even Under full load it's
definitely audible but I don't think
anyone's really going to have a heart
attack from listening to the insane
noise that it produces and in terms of
thermals it didn't H over
71° even after doing a full Benchmark
run of the super position Benchmark
which is pretty impressive but of course
this isn't the most power hungry card
out there so um it is pretty much in
line with expectations but in terms of
raw numbers for benchmarks it's a very
impressive bit of kit obviously it's not
the fastest graphics card out there at
the moment that will go to the Titan XP
or the 1080 TI but it delivers some
really strong bang for bug and if you're
in the market for a card to run 1080p
Ultra then you probably don't really
need any more than this unless you're
running at over 100 htz but having said
that if you do want to run at 1440p even
at ultra settings then it's going to be
absolutely fine as you can see from
these numbers but you may want to drop
it down to high to get a minimum of 60
FPS going above that and we still see
acceptable numbers in certain titles but
some titles especially the latest ones
and the most intensive ones will start
to struggle this isn't really a card for
over
1440p but if you're running at 1080P or
1440p and you're on a moderate budget
then this really is a very strong choice
for you comparing directly against some
other graphics cards the 1060 and the
580 both are faster but are obviously
more expensive
with the 580 in particular being 10%
faster but 15% more expensive and then
of course you've got the 460 from last
year and this card is double as quick
which really goes to show how that card
really wasn't necessarily the best
purchase because it didn't represent
brilliant value for money and then the
real last thing to mention is the fact
that this is the 4 GB variant of this
card and there is an 8 GB variant as
well that you can buy but it's not
really worth doing cuz I don't think
many people are going to going to be
able to take advant Vantage of the extra
vram that's going to be more suitable
for higher resolutions and this card
isn't going to be able to drive things
like 4K anyway so save yourself the
money get the 4 GB card and I think
you'd be very impressed with the value
proposition which is why overall this
wins The editor's Choice Award it's a
fantastic graphics card and if you want
to build a budget system that can still
play all the latest and greatest titles
at high to ultra settings depending on
the resolution you go for it's a really
impressive bit of kit but let me know
what you thought um down in the comments
section below is this powerful enough
for you is this got enough value for you
or you going to wait for something else
obviously a massive thank you to am for
supplying this review sample like the
video if you like it dislike it if you
didn't thanks as always to cor for
sponsoring the channel and I'll see you
in the next one